Now it's your turn to implement the functionality to
set and get announcements. So first you're going to need
to define the announcement class. This is a very
simple class. It just basically has one field, message and
the constructor needs to take the message and put
it in the message field. We need this class,
only because the end point functions must return an
object with a field, rather than a string. And you're
going to need to implement the SetAnnouncementServelet, you'll have
to implement the doGet method, you'll need to get the
memcache service. You'll actually have to write the logic to
construct the announcement. And then you are going to need
to put the announcement in memcache, keyed off the recent
announcements key. And then do not forget to configure your
sever in web.xml. There is a skeleton implementation of SetAnnouncementServer
available to you. If you'd like to use it, and
you can find that in the Lesson 5 folder.
You're also welcome to create it from scratch if
you want. And then in the ConferenceAPI class, you
need to add the getAnnouncement function, which is an endpoint
function, which gets the announcement out of Memcache, and
returns it, as an announcement object. And after you've tested
it and it's working on localhost, go ahead and
deploy it to appspot. And then you go to cron/set_announcement
to actually run the setAnnouncement function and again,
the web browser is not going to change. Whatever it's
showing when you go to this URL, it'll continue
to show after it executes the function. And in
the APIs explorer, you can test the getAnnouncement function
to get the values of the announcement out of
memcache. And then use memcache viewer to check that
your announcements are in memcache. Obviously they will be
if getAnnouncement works but it's good to practice using
the memcache viewer. And you can actually get the value
of the entry that's keyed by recent announcements. So
go ahead and do that. And then when everything's working,
on your app, deployed on appspot, go ahead and
enter your app ID here. As you're testing the get
and setAnnouncement functionm you're going to obviously need to make
sure that you have some conferences where the seats available
is between 0 and 5. Otherwise, you won't get
any results and you won't get any announcement saved.